[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome back to our
AdWords API series.
I'm Xerxes, a Developer
Advocate here at Google.
In the last episode,
we got you all set up
to make your first API call.
If you made it through
all of that, relax.
The hard part is over.
The rest is a piece of cake.
In this episode, we'll
take a closer look
at the ingredients you need to
cook up an AdWords API call.
If you haven't seen the
AdWords API overview video,
click this link here and
come back when you're done.
Again, we're going to be using
the Java client library, along
with Eclipse, but
the concepts are
the same for the other
language libraries as well.
Here's what we'll discuss
in this video-- test
versus production accounts
and application configuration
ingredients.
So let's get going.
In the last video, you created a
test [? MTC ?] account and then
a test client account.
A test account is an
extremely useful tool
for trying out
API functionality,
because it won't
affect your live ads
or charge your account.
The test account is also
useful for playing around
with the AdWords web interface
without consequences.
When signed into the
AdWords web interface,
this label reminds you that
you're in a test account.
Keep in mind that since test
accounts don't serve any ads,
impressions or cost data
will often be zeroed out
in reports or API calls.
Now, let's dig into
the configuration
ingredients of an API call.
In this video series, we're
using a client library
to access the AdWords API.
So we won't be going
into the back end details
of how API calls are made.
But if you want to
know more about SOAP,
OAuth 2, and the other plumbing
that make these calls work,
check out the basic
concepts here.
Even when using the
client libraries,
there are some ingredients
you will always need.
We set them up together
in episode two,
but let's recap and explain
them a bit more now.
Remember, they're all found
in your ads.properties file.
Developer token.
This identifies your
application to the AdWords API.
Only approved tokens
can connect to the API
for real AdWords accounts.
Pending tokens can connect
to test AdWords accounts.
Once your token is approved,
you can use the same token
for requests against all
your AdWords account,
including those that are not
linked to the developer's
tokens [? MTC ?] account.
Client ID and client secret.
These map your application to a
project in the Google Developer
Console and are
used for OAuth 2.
Client customer ID.
This is the account number
of the AdWords client account
you'll want to
manage via the API.
Optionally, it can be left
out of the ads.properties file
and set programmatically.
Once your developer
token is approved,
you can use a real client
customer ID here and not
just a test.
OAuth 2 access token.
If you're using
the client library,
this will be taken
care of for you.
If not, take a look at this
link to learn about the access
token.
Refresh token.
The client library
uses a refresh token
to automatically regenerate
the OAuth 2 access token.
We created this by means of a
utility in the client library
in episode two.
All right.
Now you understand all of the
ingredients for your first API
application.
In the next video, we'll look
at how code samples will get you
started with custom reporting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]